The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality,
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
BOGDAN FEDELES: Hello, and
welcome to 5.07 Bio Chemistry
Online.
I'm Dr. Bogdan Fedeles.
Let's metabolize some problems.
Today we're going to be
talking about Problem 2
of Problem Set 4.
Here we're going to be
discussing in detail
the mechanism of HMG-CoA
synthase, a key enzyme
in central metabolism
responsible for making the five
carbon building
blocks from which
all sterols, such as cholesterol
and steroid hormones are made.
HMG-CoA synthase catalyzes
the following reaction.
It takes acetyl-CoA,
which we're going
to encounter a lot in
the central metabolism,
and combines it with
acetoacetyl-CoA,
another thioester.
In this process, the one
molecule of CoA is lost,
and we get the product
hydroxymethylglutaryl
CoA or HMG-CoA, as you notice
the initials H, M, and G are
part of this name.
To help us understand
the mechanism,
a crystal structure of
this HMG-CoA synthase
is provided in this problem,
and it's shown here.
Question 1 of this
problem is asking
us to provide a
detailed curved arrow
mechanism of the
reaction catalyzed
by the HMG-CoA synthase.
And for that we're going to
use the information provided
in the crystal structure.
And we are also given
an additional hint
and that is the
acetyl CoA substrate
provides the CH2CO2 CO2 minus
moiety in the HMG-CoA product.
Let's take a look.
So the hint is telling us
that these two carbons, which
I'm going to label in
blue from acetyl-CoA,
are, in fact, these
two carbons, CH2 COO
minus in
hydroxymethylglutaryl CoA.
That means that the other
four carbons in the product
must be the carbons from
the acetoacetyl-CoA.
Let's label these red.
So now since we have a thioester
functionality in both cases,
these are probably the
same, so the carbons
from a acetoacetyl-CoA
are as follows.
So notice the
HMG-CoA synthase, it
accomplishes the formation
of a carbon-carbon bond,
and that is this
bond right here.
It's between the CH3
carbon acetyl-CoA
and the carbonyl carbon
of acetoacetyl-CoA.
And in the process,
this carbonyl
will become a hydroxyl group.
Now, let's take a look
at the crystal structure
and see what information
we can gather there.
Now this is a picture
of the active site
of the HMG-CoA synthase.
We notice the acetyl-CoA
moiety is actually
now bound to this C111.
As you know C is a cysteine--
so it's actually
covalently bound
to a cysteine-- in
the active site.
Now, notice this is
the other substrate,
which is the acetoacetyl-CoA
and bound in the active site.
So as we've discussed
before, we're
going to make this
carbon-carbon bond,
and that's going to
happen between this carbon
here and this carbon here.
So this bond needs to be formed.
However, let's take
it one step at a time.
The reaction will
start by forming
this thioester between the
acetoacetyl-CoA carbons
and the cysteine in the
active site of the enzyme.
In many reactions that use a
cysteine in the active site,
which is used to form a
covalent bond to the substrate,
we first need a base to
deprotonate the cysteine
and make it a really
good nucleophile, which
will subsequently
attack the substrate
and form a covalent bond.
Now, in a lot of these cases,
the base is a histidine.
Let's take a look if we see
a histidine in our structure.
There is a histidine
in the structure, H233.
But if you look
at this histidine,
it's quite far from
our cysteine here.
Well, obviously, because
this is a projection,
this is a two-dimensional
structure so that we only
see here a projection of a
three-dimensional structure,
it's very hard for us to
tell if this histidine is,
in fact, close enough to
deprotonate this cysteine.
So even though we have
this crystal structure,
from this one picture, we do
not have enough information
to figure out, well,
what is the base that
will deprotonate cysteine before
it reacts with acetyl-CoA.
Remember this is often the case
with crystal structures that
because of the resolution
which we can collect them,
we cannot see the protons.
And if we cannot
see the protons,
it's very hard to tell which
amino acid residues are
protonated and can serve as a
general acid or general bases.
A lot of the
researcher's intuition
comes into play to draw
these kind of structures.
And it's only with collecting
many different kinds
of experimental evidence
that we can put together
a more definitive mechanism.
Therefore, we might
not know for sure
from this one picture, which
is the general base that
deprotonates the
cysteine at 111.
So we're not going
to assign it for now.
Let's try to write the
mechanism for that part.
Here is the
acetyl-CoA substrate,
and here is the active
site cysteine 111
with its thiol group.
And again, we're not
going to assign it,
but there will be a base in the
active site of the enzyme that
will need to deprotonate this
cysteine before it can react.
Therefore, the
reaction first involves
activation of the cysteine,
is deprotonated, and then
cysteine can attack
the thioester
and form a tetrahedral
intermediate.
As we've seen it before,
for a lot of these reactions
involving thioesters.
In the first step, we
will form four bonds
to this carbonyl
carbon, and we have
formed a new bond between
the thiol of the cysteine 111
and the starting
material, acetyl-CoA.
Of course, there is a
negative charge here.
And our base in the
active site of the enzyme
will now be protonated.
Now that the
tetrahedral intermediate
is going to fall apart by
kicking off the CoA moiety.
Of course, this will get
protonated presumably
by the same base.
Now it's a general acid
that will protonate a CoA.
So we obtain the thioester with
the cysteine in the active site
and one molecule of CoA
is going to be leaving.
And here is our base.
Notice the tetrahedral
intermediate
that we're forming here.
We have an oxygen that
develops a negative charge.
And this is very similar to
the kinds of intermediate
you've seen in the serine
protease mechanism.
Now in that case,
such an intermediate
was stabilized
with hydrogen bonds
from the backbone of the
protein in a structure that
was called an oxyanion hole.
Now let's take a look at the
crystal structure of HMG-CoA
to see how a tetrahedral
intermediate might
be stabilized.
Here is the acetyl of the
acetoacetyl-CoA substrate.
The acetyl now is
bound to the cysteine
111 here in the active site.
Now, let's take a look if there
are any other residues close
enough to this oxygen. One
of them that's shown here
is this NH, which belongs to an
amide bond, the backbone amide,
and that's part of the
amino acid serine 307.
So this distance
here, C3.06 Angstrom,
it's actually close enough for
a fairly good hydrogen bond.
Presumably, this interaction
will stabilize the binding
of acetyl-CoA in this
region of the active site
and may also be
involved in catalyzing
the reaction with the
cysteine by stabilizing
the tetrahedral intermediate.
In that case, this
distance will have
to become even smaller, that is
to form a really good hydrogen
bond on the order of
2.6, 2.7 Angstrom.
Since this is only one
snapshot of the reaction,
we don't have enough
information to tell if this is
a key catalytical interaction.
Once acetyl-CoA has
reacted with the enzyme,
hence, formed the thioester
with the cysteine 111,
we're now ready to
proceed with the reaction
and form a carbon-carbon bond.
Let's take a look.
So in the next step
of the reaction,
we want to form a carbon-carbon
bond between this methyl
group here and this
carbon of the carbonyl
of the other substrate.
So first of all, we need to
deprotonate this methyl group.
We're going to form an enolate.
Then the enolate is going
to attack this carbonyl.
Once again, we look for a
suitable base, and we see,
for example, this glutamate
79 may be, in fact,
serving as a general base to
deprotonate the methyl group
here and form the enolate.
Once the enolate is formed, it's
going to attack this carbonyl,
and this oxygen
is going to start
developing a negative charge,
which needs to be compensated
by a general acid.
And it looks like this
histidine 233 is close enough
to donate a proton and
generate a hydroxyl group here.
All right.
So let's try to write
a mechanism based
on what we just said.
Here is the thioester between
cysteine 111 and acetyl.
And let's show the general base.
It's going to be glutamate 79.
Because it's a base, I'm going
to put a negative charge on it.
There you go.
And this will serve
to deprotonate
the methyl from the acetyl,
moiety here, and generate
an enolate.
So it's picking up a
proton, electron move,
and it's going to generate,
as before, a negative charge
on the oxygen, which
may be stabilized
by that interaction with
the [INAUDIBLE] hydrogen
that we just discussed.
Now, let's try this again.
And here is our enolate.
In the next step,
the enolate now
is going to attack the
carbonyl of the acetoacetyl-CoA
and form the carbon-carbon bond.
All right.
This is the
acetoacetyl-CoA, and we
discussed that
next to this oxygen
there is our histidine
233, which we're going
to show it as being protonated.
Therefore, the reaction
proceeds as follows.
Here we're forming the
carbon-carbon bond.
Then the oxygen is
going to pick up
the proton from the
protonated histidine
and it's going to
form a hydroxyl group.
Therefore, we get
cysteine 111 is still
attached to what is known
the HMG-CoA product.
So this is our carbon.
This is the new
carbon-carbon bond.
We have here a methyl group.
We have the new hydroxyl,
which were formed here,
and the rest of the molecule.
And our histidine, it
was protonated here,
now it's going to
be deprotonated.
So we just saw how the
carbon-carbon bond is formed
in the course of this reaction.
And now we're left with
a six-carbon thioester
with a cysteine 111 in the
active side of the enzyme.
Therefore, the last
step of the reaction
would involve hydrolysis of this
thioester to free the product
and regenerate the system.
So for the last step, we need
to hydrolyze this thioester,
and for that,
we're going to need
to activate a water molecule.
Once again, we don't know--
here is the water molecule--
we don't know what's the
general base, the residue
in the active site, which
removed this proton from water
to allow it to attack the
carbonyl of the thioester.
So we're going to call it
a general base attached
to the enzyme.
So this base is going to
pick a proton from water,
and then the water is going
to add to the carbonyl
and once again generate a
tetrahedral intermediate.
Say, this the OH
from water, and this
is the rest of the molecule.
Once again, this is a
tetrahedral intermediate, very
similar to the one we
saw in the first step
when we formed this thioester,
and presumably, it's
going to be stabilized in
a fairly similar manner.
Let's also show that this
base attached to the enzyme
is now protonated,
and it would probably
donate this proton to
reprotonate the cysteine
and reform that thiol group.
So in the second step,
thiol takes the electrons,
which picks up the proton
from the general base
in the active site.
So at this point,
we're just going
to release the thiol
of the cysteine 111,
and the rest of the molecule
is exactly our product,
which is the HMG-CoA.
The curved arrow
mechanism we just wrote
answers part 1 of the problem.
Second question
of this problem is
asking about the
stabilization of
the tetrahedral intermediate,
which actually we
have just discussed.
But let me reiterate
as you guys saw
in the serine
protease mechanisms,
whenever we're forming this
tetrahedral intermediate,
they tend to be stabilized
in an oxyanion hole, which
is basically a structure of the
enzyme, which can form hydrogen
bonds with the partial negative
charge or full negative charge
that develops in a
tetrahedral intermediate.
Presumably, similar
structure exists
for this HMG-CoA synthase, but
because we're only given one
snapshot, one crystal
structure, that is not
sufficient information
to say for sure which
are the key interactions
to stabilize
these tetrahedral intermediates.
A lot more work, a lot
more experimental data
is necessary to figure out
which are the key hydrogen bonds
and interactions that stabilize
the tetrahedral intermediates.
Question 3 is asking us to
review the mechanisms by which
enzymes can achieve
their amazing rate
acceleration, which is on
the order of 10 to the 6
to 10 to 15 times over
the uncatalyzed reaction
and of course, to point out
these mechanisms in the context
of the HMG-CoA synthase.
As you have seen over
and over in this course,
the three general
mechanisms by which
enzymes accelerate reactions
are binding energy,
general acid/general
base catalysis
and covalent catalysis.
Now let's take a
look at our structure
and figure out how each
one of these mechanisms
might be operating.
To start off,
covalent catalysis,
it's pretty obvious here the
acetyl-CoA substrate first
reacts and forms a covalent
bond with the cysteine
of the HMG-CoA synthase.
So this covalent
attachment to the enzyme
allows this residue to
be positioned just right
so that it can react
with the other substrate.
Now, general acid/general
base catalysis,
we've seen all these
residues that participate.
Obviously, in order
for this to react,
we need a base to
deprotonate the cysteine.
Then we need a base,
presumably, this glutamate 79,
to deprotonate the methyl
group here to form the enolate.
And we need an acid
to stabilize and form
this hydroxyl group that will
be developing on this oxygen.
So covalent catalysis and
general acid/general base
catalysis, that's
pretty obvious.
Now when it comes
to binding energy,
this is not something
that we can obviously
derive from the
structure, but we
can postulate the number of
ways in which binding energy
contributes to this reaction.
First of all, both
of the substrates
need to bind to the enzyme.
In order to do that, they
need to be desolvated,
that is to remove all the water
molecules that surround them.
So that by itself
requires energy.
The binding energy
is also derived
by when we align the
substrates in the active site
of the enzyme, we align them
so closely the right geometry
and within a few
tenths of an Angstrom
so that the right
orbitals overlap and allow
the reaction to happen.
So also the ability
to align this residue
so closely that also contributes
to the binding energy.
And finally, the
binding energy also
manifests when we're
stabilizing, for example,
the transition state
of the reaction
relative to the binding
of the substrates.
So if, for example, for our
tetrahedral intermediate
that will form here, if
that transition state
or the tetrahedral
intermediate is stabilized more
than the substrate, then
the reaction is accelerated
and proceeds towards that pass.
Part 4 of the
problem is asking us
to look up the structure
of coenzyme A, or CoA
and then contrast the
reactivity of say, acetyl-CoA,
the thioester with CoA, with
the reactivity of a thioester
with a much smaller thiol group.
Let's see what the
coenzyme A looks like.
Here we have the
structure coenzyme A.
The business end
of the molecule is
this thiol group,
which is attached
to a substantially long arm.
And at the end here, we
have, as you can recognize,
two phosphates, the ribose
and the base adenine.
This is a nucleotide is ADP.
There's also another
phosphate here.
But the business end of the
molecule is this thiol group,
and we're asked to contrast
whether a thioester
form with coenzyme A would
behave similarly to a thioester
form with this right-hand
portion of the molecule, which
I wrote here.
So it's a much shorter thiol.
Now, it turns out these
thioesters will be very, very
similar because really it's
only the thiol moiety that we
need to form thioester.
So those thioesters will
behave very, very similarly.
Now, the advantage of
having such a long arm
for the coenzyme A is
that it provides a way
to insert the substrate,
which will attach here,
to say, acetyl-CoA, to insert
acetyl-CoA in very deep
into the active
site of the enzyme.
Having a long arm to guide the
thioester may be important.
As you will see
later in the course,
fatty acid synthases, which are
these mega dalton complexes,
have multiple active sites.
So the fatty acid
attaches a thioester
to coenzyme A allows
it to be moved
through different active
sites and through a same kind
of chemistry in multiple
steps over and over again.
The advantage of having
a coenzyme A thioester
is that it may provide some
additional binding energy.
That nucleotide
portion of coenzyme A
may interact specifically
with the enzyme
near the active site,
whereas, a much smaller thiol
like the one we
just saw will not
have that kind of
interaction available.
Since we've been
talking about thioesters
throughout this entire
problem, the last question
is asking us to
rationalize why we're
seeing thioesters in metabolism
as opposed to oxygen esters.
Now, the key message you
need to remember here
is that the resonance that
we observe in oxygen esters
is almost completely
absent in thioesters.
And this fact makes the
thioesters less stable
and therefore, more reactive.
Not only their carbonyl
group behaves more
like a ketone group, but
their alpha hydrogens
are more acidic.
Let's take a look.
Here is an oxygen
ester that shows
a proton in alpha position.
And as you know, the
lone pairs on this oxygen
can conjugate with
the carbonyl group
and form certain resonance
structures, one of which
being this one.
So the electrons
can move like this,
and then we're going to
have a negative charge here
and a positive charge here.
And this is possible because
the electrons on both oxygens
are found in orbitals
of comparable energies.
By contrast, in the case of a
thioester, we have a sulfur.
Now, the electrons
on the sulfur are
in orbitals that are not
in comparable energies
with the ones on the
ketyl group and therefore,
this kind of conjugation
does not, in fact, happen.
And because this doesn't
happen, therefore, the electrons
on the carbonyl stay
localized, and that
makes the carbonyl a
better reactive site.
So it's a better electrophile
to react as nucleophiles
behaves more like a ketone.
For the same reason, when
we are to deprotonate
the alpha position
on a thioester,
the density on the
carbonyl is there
to stabilize the enolate
much more so than it
would be for an oxygen ester.
Therefore, the pKa,
the acidity constant
for this hydrogen
on the thioesters
is close to 18, which
is smaller, therefore
more acidic than the pKa of
the alpha position in oxygen
esters, which is 22.
This sums up Problem
2 of Problem Set 4.
I hope you now have a
much better feel of how
we can use crystal
structured data
to propose a
reasonable mechanism
for enzyme catalyzed reactions.
Keep in mind that writing
mechanisms on paper
is relatively easy.
But to truly confirm that
that mechanism is taking place
in real life inside
the cells, it
takes a lot more experimental
work and evidence.